So now we know how to provide the daily
special in different languages.
But how do we take the user's
food preference into account?
That doesn't seem to be a predefined
variable for food preference.
They might be vegan,
they might prefer fish.
We want to show them a special
that suits their taste.
So we're going to use
the tag manager's data layer.
Your app can put values in the data
layer by setting data layer variables.
Then, tag manager can get
the values from the data layer.
And use them to figure out which
variable values for your app to use.
So now I'm going to look
specifically at the daily special.
So the user chooses a food preference,
and
the app can put that preference in
the food preferable in the data lay out.
And then, the triggers in the tag
manager can use a data layer variable.
To determine which
variable value to use for
your app to display the daily special.
So if the food pref is to prefer meat,
you get a meat special.
If you prefer fish,
you get a fish special.
If you want vegetarian,
you get a veggie special.
And if you chose vegan, well,
you get a vegan special.
Let's go find out how to
make our app do this.